.
HE HAS CHAMPIONED VACCINATION
WHERE HE WAS ATTACKED AND
SMEARED.
JOHN KENNEDY, REPUBLICAN
SENATOR FROM LOUISIANA JOINS US
NOW.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
IS RON DESANTIS, IS HE RIGHT TO
RAMP UP THIS FIGHT?
>> WELL, WE LIVE IN A SYSTEM
WHERE BOTH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND THE STATE
GOVERNMENTS SHARE POWER.
AND ON AN ISSUE LIKE THIS QUITE
FRANKLY I THINK THE DECISION
SHOULD BE MADE STATE BY STATE
BY THE STATE LEGISLATURE OR IN
SOME CASES THE GOVERNOR WITH
AUTHORITY FROM THE STATE
LEGISLATURE.
I THINK IN TERMS OF THE
LOCKDOWNS, SANDRA, I DON'T
THINK WE ARE GOING TO GO BACK
TO ANOTHER LOCKDOWN.
I JUST DON'T THINK THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WILL STAND FOR IT.
NUMBER TWO, ON THE MASKS, MY
ATTITUDE ABOUT THE MASKING OR
NOT WEARING A MASK, IT IS A
SIDE SHOW.
IT IS A SUBORDINATE ISSUE AND
DISTRACTION.
IF YOU WANT TO WEAR A MASK,
WEAR ONE, IF YOU DON'T, DON'T.
THE MASK UNLESS IT IS AN N-95
AND WORN PROPERLY, THERE IS
BENEFIT BUT ONLY A MARGINAL
BENEFIT.
TO ME THE ISSUE IS THE VACCINE.
NOW, I DON'T BELIEVE ANY
GOVERNMENT SHOULD REQUIRE
ANYBODY TO TAKE THE VACCINE.
IT IS UP TO THE INDIVIDUAL.
THE BILL OF RIGHTS IS THERE TO
PROTECT OUR -- IS NOT THERE TO
CONTROL PEOPLE, IT IS THERE TO
CONTROL GOVERNMENT.
BUT I BELIEVE IN THE VACCINE.
I HAVE TAKEN TWO SHOTS AND AS
SOON AS A BOOSTER IS AVAILABLE
I WILL TAKE THE THIRD SHOT.
THE VIRUS CAME FROM CHINA, THE
BEST VACCINES CAME FROM AMERICA.
AND THEY WORK.
>> Sandra: WHAT WE NEED TO DEAL
WITH IS THE FACTS.
I CAN TELL YOU THIS, THERE IS A
BRIEFING THAT IS HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW WITH THE COVID
RESPONSE TEAM CDC DIRECTOR
WALENSKY IS SPEAKING RIGHT NOW.
A MOMENT AGO THE WHITE HOUSE
CORONAVIRUS RESPONSE
COORDINATOR WAS SPEAKING AND HE
SAID THEY CAN NOW SAY THAT 1/3
OF THE NEW CASES ARE COMING
FROM FLORIDA AND TEXAS.
SO TO GO BACK TO THE WHITE
HOUSE SAYING THAT THEY WANT A
COORDINATED RESPONSE TO THIS
VIRUS AND HOPE THAT THE
GOVERNOR OF FLORIDA JUMPS IN,
DO YOU BELIEVE THE GOVERNORS OF
THESE STATES ARE DOING ENOUGH.
I'LL POINT OUT IN YOU ARE
STATE, THE GREAT STATE OF
LOUISIANA, YOUR STATE IS BOTTOM
OF THE LIST AS FAR AS
VACCINATION RATES.
FIFTH FROM THE BOTTOM.
37% OF YOUR POPULATION IS FULLY
VACCINATED.
SO ARE THESE STATES DOING
ENOUGH TO COMBAT THIS VIRUS?
>> NUMBER ONE, IT'S A VERY
FEROCIOUS VIRUS AS WE KNOW.
NUMBER TWO, I THINK THE
GOVERNORS OF FLORIDA AND
ALABAMA AND LOUISIANA AND
TEXAS, THEY ARE ALL DOING THE
BEST THEY CAN.
NUMBER THREE, I THINK SURE
THERE ARE A LOT OF CASES COMING
OUT OF TEXAS AND FLORIDA.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
FLORIDA, DUH.
NUMBER FOUR, I THINK ONE OF THE
BIGGEST PROBLEMS WE HAVE
SANDRA, YOU TOUCHED ON IT.
NOBODY KNOWS WHO TO BELIEVE
ANYMORE.
AND I THINK IF I WERE KING FOR
A DAY -- I'M NOT AND DON'T
ASPIRE TO BE -- I WOULD APPOINT
ONE PERSON IN WHOM THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE HAVE CONFIDENCE HERE IN
WASHINGTON, NOT A POLITICIAN,
TO TRY TO ANSWER PEOPLE'S
QUESTIONS.
NOW, FAIR OR NOT I DON'T THINK
THAT'S DR. FAUCI.
I LIKE DR. FAUCI AND RESPECT
HIM, BUT FAIR OR NOT ABOUT HALF
OF AMERICANS TRUST DR. FAUCI
NOW LIKE THEY WOULD TRUST BILL
COSBY AS THE BARTENDER.
THAT'S JUST A FACT.
I'M NOT SAYING I'M HAPPY THAT'S
THE CASE.
MAYBE DR. WALENSKY IS THE
ANSWER.
MAYBE DR. COLLINS AT N.I.H.
WE HAVE TO HAVE ONE PERSON.
LEADERSHIP MATTERS.
>> Sandra: WE LOOK AT THE TEXAS
GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT SAYING HE
WILL NOT REIMPOSE MASK MANDATES
OR SHUT DOWN BUSINESSES AGAIN.
>> TEXAS HAS REMAINED OPEN FOR
BUSINESSES DURING THE COURSE OF
THE PANDEMIC.
SAFE PRACTICES ARE IMPORTANT.
THAT SAID, ONE THING THAT WE
LEARNED ALONG THE WAY IS
LOCKDOWNS ARE WRONG DURING THE
COURSE OF A PANDEMIC.
>> Sandra: IT SEEMS TO BE HE IS
RULING THAT OUT, SENATOR.
I WILL FINISH OFF WITH THIS.
I OPEN FROM OUR BRAIN ROOM A
DAILY COVID REPORT AND TELLS US
WHERE WE ARE.
EVERYBODY LOOKS AT DIFFERENT
METRICS.
NEW CASES, 43% INCREASE WEEK
OVER WEEK IN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
THE HOSPITALIZATION RATE WHICH
MANY PEOPLE LOOK TO UP 45%
HOSPITALIZATIONS WEEK OVER WEEK
IN THE UNITED STATES.
DEATHS ARE UP 40% WEEK OVER
WEEK.
YOU SEE THE POLLING, PEOPLE
JUST A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO
THOUGHT THINGS WERE GETTING
BETTER.
NOT SO MUCH ANYMORE.
PEOPLE ARE  WORRIED IN THE
DIRECTION WE'RE GOING.
>> DON'T GET DISTRACTED.
THE ISSUE IS THE VACCINE.
WE NEED TO SPEND ALL OF OUR
EFFORTS TRYING TO CONVINCE
FOLKS THAT THE COSTS OF THE
VACCINE ARE SUBSTANTIALLY LESS
THAN THE BENEFIT.
WE ARE DOING OKAY IN LOUISIANA
IN TERMS OF IMPROVEMENT THERE.
WE'RE UP 3 OR 4% IN TERMS OF
VACCINATION RATE.
THAT'S THE ONLY THING THAT WILL
GET US OUT OF THIS.
LET ME SAY IT AGAIN.
IF YOU DON'T WANT TO TAKE THE
VACCINE, DON'T TAKE IT.
SOME WON'T.
BUT I BELIEVE IN IT.
I THINK IT WORKS.
IF THEY TOLD ME TO TAKE THE
VACCINE, I HAD TO TAKE IT BY
GETTING A SHOT IN THE EYEBALL,
I WOULD.
I DON'T WANT TO DIE.
I DON'T WANT TO SEE MY FELLOW
AMERICANS DIE.
AND I BELIEVE THE VACCINE WORKS
AND WE NEED TO MAKE OUR CASE
BUT GOVERNMENT CAN'T REQUIRE
PEOPLE TO DO IT.
I JUST DON'T THINK IT'S
CONSTITUTIONAL.
>> Sandra: THAT'S WHER